but you may remember one of the things
we developed was a conical pendulum
um question algorithm a set of steps
right that you can take and you can
apply them pretty much to any conical
pendulum question and it should do
pretty well okay
now i should mention right algorithms
get a bad name
and the reason why they get a bad name
is because you can use an algorithm
without understanding why it works
right so if i gave you something like
this
uh b squared minus four or maybe i'll
make that a minus
okay so here's a um here's a pretty
typical quadratic and you can teach
i think in year seven is when you first
learn algebra and substitution so you
could teach a
like a 12 year old how to do this you
can say look
the a and the b and the c they're meant
to be here here and here
and then you just have to punch it in
and out you get a number or a pair of
numbers at the
end okay that's an algorithm and you can
crunch through the algorithm and get to
the end of the algorithm
and get an answer from the algorithm
without any understanding at all
of why okay so what you guys have to
make sure is as we go through these
do you know why we're doing them or we
revisit it after
we go through an example of this okay so
can you remember
what were the steps of the algorithm the
first one's the easiest one
good got a diagram tell me remind me
what goes on the diagram
mainly it's it's forces that we're
interested in okay specifically
the physical ones give me some examples
of physical forces that you'll see
gravity uh tension in a string
um uh the reaction force off of a
surface okay
so they're all on there after you've
drawn that then what do you do
you appeal to some like stuff you learn
like a couple years ago
trig or whatever geometry like parallel
lines and all that kind of thing
why are we doing that what's the point
of that what's the goal
ah not yet we haven't got there yet
we've only just done this
we've just done this you need to know
like forces forces are vector quantities
right they're vector quantities which
means they have two
two parts to them what are the two parts
there's a
direction right and then there's a
magnitude
okay so what you're doing is you work
out the direction
and magnitude of all of the different
forces and you use trig to do it
right you'll be like oh this one's n cos
theta or that one's t
sine alpha or whatever it is okay
all right after you've worked a lot then
you resolve the forces
and of course you resolved them into
okay you're sold into two different
parts
right what will you expect the vertical
forces
to resolve to remember it's uniform
circular motion
should be zero it's not going up and
down okay it's just making that nice
horizontal circle okay what does the
horizontal force
or the horizontal forces what do they
resolve to
m r omega squared or alternatively if
you don't know what angular velocity is
what's the other way we can write it m
v squared on r in case what you're given
in the question is oh it's going around
at
two meters a second or something like
that okay so that's what you're
expecting
final step solve good
depending on whatever it is that they
ask you for maybe it's a it's the
tension
or the reaction force or whatever it is
you want to solve the force equations
okay now can we just pause for a second
like i said algorithms get bad
press because sometimes people use them
without knowing
why you do any of them right so
why these things why that order why are
they useful to us
a classic example question is what's the
tension
right in fact i'm going to ask you one
of these in a second okay
so what do you need to know in order to
solve
for this to work out the tension well
clearly you need to know what the force
equations are
right horizontal and vertical okay
they'll show you some relationship
between
tension gravity reaction force whatever
okay
but to get these well you had to resolve
all of the forces in the first place
so that you equate them to these which
is what uniform circular motion does
right just like um you know just like in
simple harmonic motion
you'd say well it's got to do this oops
right so you're like okay i'll fit it
into that and then i can solve stuff
from there
okay but of course to work out what any
of these quantities are
you need to work out how big they are
and which way they're facing what angles
are going on and that's where the trig
comes in
right well you're not going to be able
to do much useful trigger geometry
unless you've got a decent diagram that
shows you where everything is pointing
does that make sense do you see how
there's logic to it please
please don't just do these because i
said so i mean i mean
do do them because i said so but don't
do them only because i said so right
you've got to know why so let's apply it
example a hemispherical bowl
let's do it like this um
hmm
let's consider this in general forms
general terms
first and then i'll put some specific
values on it and we'll solve for a
particular kind of thing
okay so here you go typical example
it's um it's a bowl and it's in the
shape of half a sphere so that's nice
and easy to work out
okay um you've got an angle up here
theta
okay and you've got this string
holding this so that it goes in uniform
circular motion
okay so let's start we've got the
diagram
i haven't put any forces on here what
forces would you like
to suggest for me to draw on
gravity gravity i'll put tension on a
second gravity is usually the first
place i start
okay because it's always the same every
single time so it's mg
down in that direction okay the next one
suggested was tension okay where's
tension going
it's going it's going up along the
stream okay so
something like this
and we'll call that t okay
tension gravity are we done
ah there's a normal force involved
because i'm resting on the surface
but there's a bit of a problem here
let's go back to our example before
this was yesterday afternoon of the cone
right so it's facing up
and i have the um drawing out circle
like so
and then i got out my diary and my keys
and we talked about
the reaction force that that surface
that any surface
is exerting and it's a normal force
right
so there's a right angle there no
problems okay um
except where does my right angle go
at the moment which way does it face
because the problem is like depending on
like if i was here or here or here
i'll be facing all different directions
right so which way am i going
tension now be careful
right um if for instance i um let's just
let's just do an example okay
suppose uh it was spinning super super
fast right
so it was up and it was the actual
particles over here
right okay so you can see obvious
obviously the tension's going
up on the string okay but here it's a
little more clear right because it's a
hemisphere
so this part here should be vertical i
didn't draw a very vertical but you get
the idea
so if this is vertical which way is
the normal it should be
horizontal right like vertical
perpendicular means
horizontal okay so you're going you're
definitely not going in the same
direction as the string
right so tension is going that way from
the string
but the normal force is facing another
direction okay now
it's actually not that hard to work out
when you think about it
here's a circle so now i'm looking um
i'm looking
right on so i'm looking kind of at an
angle right now downwards into the bowl
okay
but let's sort of go down a little lower
right so all i can see is just
well i'm just going to chop it in half
okay now the normal force
is going to be perpendicular to
the tangent force right because that's
what tangents and normals do
but the tangent is perpendicular at the
point of conduct contact
to what to the to the radius right
so in other words this normal force
right wherever i
am it's going to be pointed to the
center that's why if i'm right up here
i'm pointing horizontally to the that
midpoint right there
okay i'm actually down here so in order
to draw this force in i need a bit more
information
i sort of cheated you okay so i'm going
to rub off this green pretend bit
what i really need is i need the center
i need the center
of the if this ball was a sphere
wouldn't be a very useful ball but it
would have a center about here wouldn't
it okay so i'm going to draw that in
uh something like that
so there's the center of that top sort
of surface right and that
along here that is the direction
that the normal force is going in right
perpendicular to the surface of
the okay
so am i done with my diagram have i
accounted for all the physical forces
i think it looks good i think it looks
good you've got the string accounted for
you've got the ball accounted for your
gravity accounted for
we're not worrying about friction or
anything like that it's done okay
so now i need to appeal to trig and
geometry to try and sort these things
out
how big are these things and which
direction exactly are they facing
right so to do that actually i should
put this over here
okay i've got my feeder up here i'll
need to call this some other angle
because clearly it is some other angle
it's not going to be the same as theta
because
they're not parallel right so i'm just
going to call that alpha
is that all right
now in the past what we've done is we
have drawn more horizontal and vertical
forces
coming off of the particle because
that's where they're acting right so
i've got
in this case i'm going to have a
vertical component of
tension and then a vertical component of
the normal
and then i'll have a horizontal
component of each just like this
the same but they're right on top of
each other this is going to be a bad
idea so i'm just going to draw off to
the side
two separate diagrams
one for the tension and one for the
normal
okay i'm just trying to make sure my
diagrams are clear and not make it all
muddled up
right let's do the tension first okay so
there's the actual direction of the
force and now i want the
horizontal and vertical bits right right
angle there
now look at this diagram here where
would this triangle be situated
right in here right so that's a vertical
there you've got
corresponding angles so theta
is up there happy on that
there's t that's that magnitude okay of
that tension right
so you use trig in this trig and you get
this right
what's the upward force what's the
vertical part
it's going to be t cos theta right
because this is adjacent to the angle
i'm after
so t cos theta in that direction and
then
horizontally d sine theta because it's
opposite
so far so good now let's worry about the
normal force okay
like so but you're replaying exactly the
same thing aren't you
instead of theta you've got the alpha
over there so
alpha in the corner you can see it
starts to get quite automatic right once
you
know which way things are facing okay so
upward here
because this is n you're going to have n
cos alpha
whoops i drew that the wrong direction
sorry
it's going that way uh n sine
so that was a big thing actually you
should note that they are both facing
inward
right toward the ball neither of the
forces are making it punch through
the surface of the ball that's kind of
important okay
good i'm going to resolve them by saying
well okay like that this is step two
done
the vertical thing should be equal to
zero let's do that okay
so vertically
right i've got these two going up this
one going down and they should cancel
out because of newton's third law
okay so that gives me this t cos
theta
alpha so that's what hap is happening up
and down
and then horizontally
okay now both of these are going in
toward the center
both going in toward the center okay so
when i add them together let's see t
sine theta
and n sine alpha right they're both
facing that direction so it'll be this
if we know what angular velocity is
or it'll be this if we know what linear
velocity is
and right now we don't know anything so
i'll just write both you happy with that
okay so now i'm going to put some
numbers on all of this and i'm going to
pose two questions to you so let me
write this up and then i'll give you
some time to give it the go yourself
okay let me give you some angles and
lengths and
so then here are my two questions if the
particle's circling the ball every four
seconds
one two three four back to the start one
two three four
what's the tension in the string typical
question
this one a little more interesting if
the particle speeds up
what happens to the tension in the
string and can you account
for the reason why it changes the way
that it does
have a think about that give that ten